now now bring them back now they chant
as tens of thousands of Israelis
gathered on yet another Saturday in
solidarity with those held captive in
Gaza this time though calls for their
immediate release came directly from
some of those just freed by
Hamas I came to thank you because
without you I wouldn't be here now we
must bring back my son and
everyone many of those brought back to
Israel were separated from their loved
ones still in captivity wives from their
husbands and children from their fathers
a ceasefire deal agreement that ended on
Friday morning saw Only Women and
Children released Hamas insists that it
freed all women and children under a
ceasefire agreement that ended after
both sides blamed each other for
violations
Israel says that it didn't release an
additional 17 women and children and
that's why it's gone back to bombing
Gaza Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu says diplomatic efforts work
to release 80 captives but the only way
to get the remaining ones is by stepping
up its military pressure on
Hamas we continue to fight with all our
might this is what our Fighters were
preparing for during the ceasefire for
complete victory over Hamas while he
might be unified in his vision with a
war cabinet a separate public statement
by his defense minister yav Galant just
minutes before the prime ministers
didn't go un noticed by reporters they
questioned Netanyahu whether he'd quit
after the war he didn't give a direct
answer but those protesting outside did
he's made the pack with the most extreme
people in the government ER
fascists uh extremely religion people
and what happened on the 7th of October
is a horrific price we've paid for
having him in in charge and it's on his
watch and he and his government have to
go families of those held captive are
demanding the government revive the
ceasefire this makes no sense the duty
of all decision makers of the ministers
here is to meet with us on the weekly
basis and keep us informed to produce
more and more deals which will bring all
hostages home as early as
tomorrow the sudden end to the Poes in
fighting came as a big blow to many and
the people here say they'll keep up the
pressure until everyone is brought
back Al jazer T
Aviv make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer